[Music]
all right now a word about the
Democratic party this is a party that
claims they have a monopoly of
compassion for the poor the working
class in America but we all know that in
reality they are now the party that
caters to the Hollywood Elite Wall
Street Elite the rich and Powerful it's
a party that puts the radical climate
agenda above the working people in
America I always say the Forgotten men
and women in America and they're the
ones that are okay with importing energy
abroad doesn't impact their their wallet
that much instead of producing it
domestic oil energy right here at home
it's the party with the economic and
energy policies that are crushing the
middle class and working class in this
country it is the Democratic politicians
they're the ones that lie and say that
they're not going to raise taxes on
people making under four hundred
thousand dollars a year and what did Joe
Biden do turn around he wants taxes on
oil gas coal pensions and corporations
corporations don't pay taxes they pass
that cost on to all of us now two-thirds
of the country as a result are living
paycheck to paycheck we have people now
tapping into their pension accounts for
Bare Necessities we have other Americans
now paying bills with credit cards this
year the average household was hit with
a ten thousand dollar Biden inflation
tax that's how much he's driven this
economy into the ground now Biden says
the American taxpayer what won't pay for
is will have to pay they're not going to
pay for the billionaire uh Banker buddy
bailout of Biden uh This Is A Lie what
you're about to watch is one big huge
lie take a look no losses and I want
this is an important point no losses
will be borne by the taxpayers let me
repeat that no losses will be borne by
the taxpayers instead the money will
come from the fees that Banks pay into
the deposit Insurance Fund
who pays the fees that would be the
taxpayers another lie of Biden anyway
Biden let the Working Class People of
this country remember just like in East
Palestine they were dangling in the
toxic wind for weeks on end without
saying or doing a thing by the way when
are you going to visit East Palestine
Joe and when the ultra Elite Silicon
Valley Bank imploded on Friday it took
Joe Biden less than one business day to
send a giant pile of your cash billions
and billions of dollars to svb to ensure
that every single millionaire
billionaire Tech CEO and winemaker was
repaid in full even the uber wealthy
governor of California Gavin Newsom well
he was a client at svb three of his wine
companies three of them use the bank and
get this an executive at the bank
allegedly sits on the board of his
wife's charity but Newsom he failed to
mention any of that during his effusive
Praise of Biden's billionaire bailout
instead of making sound financial
decisions svb championed every woke
cause and social Trend imaginable they
committed five billion dollars to quote
carbon neutral operations to an
obsessive company-wide focus on Race
gender sexual orientation everything
woke the bank used all the right
buzzwords and made all the right quote
connections its board was filled with
Democratic Mega donors including one
with a passion for improv improv of the
12 board members only one had
significant banking experience as it
turns out the board's connections to the
Democratic party would prove very
valuable the self-proclaimed party of
the working class always protects their
ultra wealthy donors so both svb and the
other bank that imploded signature
that's Barney Frank's Bank donated big
money to Democrats and like svb
signature was also intertwined with the
Democratic party at as I mentioned
remember Dodd-Frank well that was named
after Barney Frank the former Democratic
congressman and co-author of the
Dodd-Frank regulatory Bill well that sat
on signatures board he was on the board
and he actively lobbied his Democratic
friends to remove regulations put in
place by his own bill naturally
signature also championed woke causes
the chairman of the bank even personally
led a seminar on gender neutral pronouns
so as you can imagine all of signatures
clients were also bailed out another
billionaire Joe Biden buddy bailout it's
your money that's being paid to pay off
everybody and by the way I guess hard
work doesn't pay off for the working men
and women in this country seems like
it's about who you know how much money
you donate what left wing cause you
champion this should make you Furious as
we speak bite Administration is now
essentially printing money to bail out
woke millionaires billionaires that
support their party and you will pay
every single penny of this and by the
way for everything sent through
inflation speaking of which inflation
contributes to this you know climb up
six percent since last year anyway here
with reaction from the hit show Shark
Tank Kevin O'Leary Mr O'Leary sir how
are you
very good thank you did I get this right
that you had money in svb a lot of money
I had uh many of companies that we
invested in our private Equity portfolio
from circle on down Circle had about 3
billion and it was the largest depositor
and others and um you know when when
you're in my situation you don't care
that much about politics you care about
policy and so you make your decisions
every day my job is to get up in the
morning and put millions of dollars to
work I really care about policy and what
I see here you know regardless of where
you stand in politics it's a pretty bad
policy because what we did in my view
it's a personal opinion over the weekend
is to nationalize the American banking
system we basically told everybody
around the world
regardless of who you are and what bank
you're in
no matter how much you have
we guarantee it we don't care who you
are or why it's there but no matter what
happens it's guaranteed so just think
about it I'd like to keep this very
simple I'm a bank manager in a bank
today after this new policy decision and
I get compensated on the value of my
bank's stock you just told me I could
take all the depottors my depositors
money go to Las Vegas Put it on red
maybe a double it maybe I lose it all
but it doesn't matter to me because you
the taxpayer and the government
guarantee all my depositors as long as I
play by the rules that we have now in
the football rules of banking I get to
go crazy
and I think this is a very bad mistake
you called it a victory for idiot bank
managers I'm not trying to get into your
own personal finances the reason I was
asking that question is that we all know
the FDIC ensures up to 250 000
I'm assuming that you had a lot more
money in there than 250 000 so you will
be the beneficiary of this of this
bailout like every other depositor at
svb however the difference between you
and probably everybody else is you're
saying this Bank should not be bailed
out am I wrong on that
no you're not this bank was run by
idiots with an incompetent board it's
One Bank no one ever heard the name
before now it's International you keep
your money Kevin you're a smart guy why
did you keep your money there if it was
run by idiots
no no it's one of many many banks I keep
my money in and look I'm a big boy and
my whole point is if you have more than
250 000 in any institution you're
basically a hedge fund or a Savvy
investor or a business you understand
your risks and you act accordingly so I
I think the fed's Mandate about keeping
FDIC insurance at 250 makes sense to me
but we changed all that over the weekend
we said it doesn't matter how much you
have and I understand we want to keep
confidence in the banking system what I
would have preferred is to allow this
Bank Run by idiots and I'm sorry to say
these harsh words but it's a fact this
is a these the you know Silicon Valley
Bank is the poster boy for idiot
management now that brand is is
radioactive waste and so at the end of
the day let this thing go under because
that's our Democratic you know
capitalist system because when you're an
idiot and it goes to zero that's okay
most of the people that had money
including me above 200 150 000 in my
portfolio companies we can take the hit
I get it that happens sometimes but I'll
tell you what I've done since then I've
told all my CEOs and all of our
portfolios we don't want any more than
20 percent in any one institution so he
Diversified across many institutions and
frankly what I see now as a as an
investor in Bank stocks I won't invest
anymore because you're basically telling
me that from now on the regulatory
environment on small Regional Banks is
going to be so punitive I don't think
they can make money anymore remember
this this is the really key issue for
everybody in America to think about
there are 11 sectors in our economy we
are the greatest economy on Earth one of
those financial services it's the only
sector that Services all other ten we
have to make a decision do we want to
turn this into utility to service the
other 10 or do you want to be private if
it's private you have have to let the
idiots go to zero and we didn't do that
this weekend all right Kevin O'Leary we
appreciate you coming on Shark Tank is
doing well congrats on that hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else